Morgens in Berlin: Hochbetrieb
in der Großküche.
149 Portionen, von dem
zweiten Salat sind‘s heute 118
und von dem dritten Salat
sind‘s 186 Salate.
Das Start-up GreenGuru
sieht eine Marktlücke:
gesundes Essen für
gestresste Großstädter.
Der Trend geht auf jeden Fall schon dahin,
dass es immer schneller alles kommen muss.
Das Stichwort ist da … "instant
gratification" nennt man das.
Dass Sie auf Knopfdruck quasi … man
seine Bedürfnisse gedeckt sehen will
und besonders in der Mittagspause
ist das sehr wichtig,
weil die meisten Leute einfach
nicht so viel Zeit haben zum Essen.
Zwei von drei Bundesbürgern legen
Wert auf gesunde Ernährung
– das sagen sie zumindest
in Umfragen.
Im Supermarkt bestätigt sich der Trend.
Besonders beliebt hier:
flüssige Snacks für die Mittagspause.
Also die Leute sind mehr bedacht
auf Frische und auf Bioprodukte,
zumindest die konventionellen
Fertigprodukte,
die Konservierungsstoffe und
irgendwelche Zusätze enthalten,
sind nicht mehr so gefragt, wie
die Sachen, die wirklich frisch sind.
Der Markt für Fertigprodukte stagniert –
ein Problem für die Hersteller.
Marktführer Nestlé
setzt auf Forschung.
Die Idee: Essen soll künftig
präventiv gegen Krankheiten wirken.
Jeder isst, was ihn gesünder macht,
je nach genetischer Disposition
und Vorerkrankung.
Die Nestlé-Deutschlandchefin
sieht einen Megatrend:
maßgeschneiderte Ernährung.
Es ist nicht mehr die gleiche Ernährung
für alle, sondern vielmehr individualisiert:
Abhängig von meinem Körper,
brauche ich vielleicht mehr dies oder das,
abhängig vom Alter, Mann oder Frau
– es sind viele Parameter dabei.
Ernährungsberatung digital
– auch das könnte bald zum Geschäft
der Lebensmittelhersteller gehören.
Dann ließe sich übrigens genau feststellen:
Wer isst tatsächlich was?
Noch gibt es da nur ungefähre
Durchschnittswerte,
zum Beispiel beim Fleisch.
Im Durchschnitt verzehrt jeder
Bundesbürger rund 60 Kilogramm im Jahr.
Doch es gibt eine Gegenbewegung.
Immer mehr Vegetarier ersetzen Fleisch,
und jeder hundertste Bundesbürger
nutzt gar keine Tierprodukte mehr.
Die Zahl an Veganern ist auch
am Wachsen in den letzten Jahren.
Natürlich, momentan ist es
ein sehr großer Boom,
der auch viel Aufmerksamkeit bekommt.
Das wird vielleicht wieder
ein bisschen abflachen.
Aber zukünftig, auf die langfristige
Entwicklung denken wir,
dass vegan auf jeden Fall
ein noch größerer Trend wird.
Im Gegenteil, sagt der
Fleischer gleich nebenan.
Vegetarier und Veganer seien
nur eine kleine Minderheit,
und sein Produkt auch in
Zukunft noch gefragt.
Unsere Kundschaft isst genauso
wie vorher das Fleisch,
sie sind beim Fleischverzehr konzentriert:
etwas weniger, aber dafür Qualität.
Beim Lieferdienst GreenGuru sind
noch ein paar Salate vom Morgen übrig.
Doch wegschmeißen
will man nichts.
Die Lösung ist digital: Das Start-Up
ResQ vertreibt Essen, das übrig blieb.
Europaweit wurden so im letzten
Jahr 100.000 Portionen
vor dem Mülleimer "gerettet".
ResQ ist eine Online-Plattform,
wo man sozusagen überschüssiges
Essen von Restaurants und Cafés
vergünstigt bestellen kann
als Privatperson.
Und es geht darum, dass wir einfach
keine Lebensmittel mehr verschwenden.
Insgesamt so, wenn man von [der]
Kilogrammmenge sich das angucken würde,
europaweit sind wir bei 30.000 Kilogramm.
Essen retten? Oder gleich nur
nach Bedarf produzieren?
Auch das ist eine Zukunftsvision:
Lebensmittel aus dem Drucker
– Menge, Farbe und Form
nach Wunsch. Guten Appetit!